alors je vous dis tout de suite bonsoir
madame bonsoir messier parce que je sais
que je n'ai pas beaucoup quand on dit
bonsoir non un laurent je vous le dis
aussi on doit pas dire bonsoir vous dire
bonsoir madame épicerie bien sûr
d'apprendre plein de choses voilà fort
madame ça le rend si vous pouviez
essayer d'éviter les ok leccia tout ça
parce que la baronne aime pas trop quoi
mais ça va de soi
j'en ai bien ainsi je dis bien se tenir
ne vous inquiétez pas on va parler de
votre livre qui s'appelle l'amour est
une affaire de femmes chez robert
laffont vous savez comment c'est un
c'est votre c'est votre septième livre
sauf qu'elle parte à psa y en a pour 500
brille
plus monsieur nafie un peu confuse chez
un
pote quelqu'un vous appelle monsieur
kadhafi en même temps ouais c'est une
fois impliqué
avant de passer avec libre on va parler
[Applaudissements]
l'un parcours absolument incroyable et
nenad in l'hôpital y est rue agathe à
puteaux est maire était ouvrière votre
père inconnu et votre beau-père et des
gardiens de la paix
vous viviez dans un petit deux pièces
obscur l'eau il fallait chercher dans la
cour et votre chien l'évasion s'était la
lecture et vous aviez trouvé un livre
poussiéreux dans un placard au fond d'un
vieux placard c'était le savoir vivre
écrit par la marquise louise d'alc et
quand vous lisiez ce livre vous aviez
l'impression de présider des dîners
somptueux où des hommes en habit
s'incliner devant des femmes sakineh
jusqu'à terre vous imaginez en lisant ce
bouquin il vit entouré de lys et de
roses et puis quand vous ouvrir les yeux
vous reveniez dans votre petit
deux-pièces de puteaux et celle là c'est
là qu'est née votre toute cette ambition
de s'en sortir oui mais à vous en tant
que j'ai l'impression que c'est les
misérables j'ai l'air de causette dans
votre
impression non mais dites vous écouter
dans le quartier tout le monde était
comme moi donc il y avait pas de raison
que je sois plus plus pauvres que les
autres crise que les autres en étaient
tous à la même info ouais alors le
premier amour s'appelait georges truchot
oui voilà c'est un fils de chiffonniers
qui il allait vous cherchez des fleurs
dans les poubelles c'est très beau cette
histoire c'est vraiment une très belle
histoire
alors vous était pas terrible quand vous
étiez petit encas trimestre les taches
de rousseur
non m'appeler s'il de faire j'ai changé
vous
si vous les fait avant lui ce serait
bien mais vous saviez déjà séduire très
tôt vous avez compris oui j'ai appris
très vite
c'est quoi votre secret je crois que
c'est la gaieté je vais vous dire il
n'ya pas un homme qui résiste à la gaîté
d'une femme à la gentillesse la gaieté
un peu de perversion bien entendu cette
fois elle est comme vous ma femme c'est
vrai elle est réglée très enjoué comme
ça le matin en se réveillant et puis la
perversion aussi
bien alors j'ai commencé à travailler à
l'âge de 14 ans chennai bailleur donc
c'est deus de voiture et vous dit dès
que j'ai eu le certif je suis parti de
chez moi donc pour travailler mais quand
vous avez été nommé docteur honoris
causa de l'université de jérusalem vous
avez déclaré pas mal pour quelqu'un qui
n'a pas son certif oui c'est vrai je ne
les ai jamais eues budget déjà mais
enfin il fallait bien qu'un jour je dis
c'est lorsque je voulais travailler que
je l'avais si vous êtes d'accord voilà
mais très courageuse dire que pour
arrondir vos fins de mois vous nettoyez
les escaliers de l'immeuble où vous
habitiez non mais là c'était les très
jeunes pour arrondir ses fins de mois
c'est dans la bio ensuite vous travaillé
dans une fabrique de laine vous mettez
des pelote dans des sacs vous avez quand
même une première vie qui était pas
drôle du tout non sans faire les
misérables il ya des tas de femmes qui
sont comme moi aujourd'hui et elles vont
pas non mais c'était absolument pas plus
je vous assure non non pas du tout alors
beaucoup d'ambitions un très jeune vous
dites je préférais rester chez moi que
sort-il mal accompagné et c'est normal
je vais vous dire quand vous voulez
réussir dans la vie il ya des tas
d'hommes autour de vous et tas de gens
qui vous sollicite pour pour être avec
vous parce que vous êtes mignonne vous
avez 16 ans bon moi je préférais rester
chez moi que d'être mal accompagné mais
la compagnie ça veut dire par un homme
qui pouvait rien nous apporter enfin
exactement l'origine deviner là j'arrive
à la fiche numéro 69 vous connaissez le
principe
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous qui me posais une question
malarone les rôles sont inversés
évidemment pour une fois c'est bien en
tant que femme de banquier je voudrais
savoir si vous avez un compte non
déclaré dans une banque étrangère
alors voilà la question c'est bien ça me
permet de bien énorme que du 18 et non
avec sa fille avait jamais rien proposé
non je sais pas faire ça je paye mes
impôts et to machine je suis pas fort là
dedans alors beaucoup d'ambition et on
peut dire pas une grosse vertus non plus
n'ont écouté tout départ ce que c'est
que ce qu'est ce que vous appelez que la
vertu est ce que c'est un homme deux
hommes trois hommes qu'est ce que c'est
oui
il ya des limites quelque part bon je
vais pas vous dire exactement si j'étais
vertueuse ou pas j'étais une jeune fille
de mon temps je crois qu'aujourd'hui
elles se valent un jour vous tombez sur
le peintre jean gabriel domergue
vous avez rendez vous avec une amie qui
voulait poser pour lui et en fait l'idée
qui vous voit il vous dit vous commencer
demain matin absolument et je vais vous
dire c'était la soeur d'elisabeth
tessier j'ai travaillé avec moi et qui
mettait les pelotes de laine dans les
sacs c'est parce qu'elle est devenue
d'ailleurs et voilà
et donc à 16 ans finalement vous
commencé à poser pour jean gabriel
domergue devient long cou comme ça un
petit nez en trompette très parisienne
comme les parisiennes donné qu'ils
rasent 1 et à leur première séance de
poses humiliation vous aviez oublié de
vous laver les cheveux
comment une fille comme vous en lac ou y
mettez ça peut arriver nul n'est parfait
elle nous a renvoyés chez vous il vous a
dit il ya toujours du savant dans une
maison exactement renvoyé chez vous et
allez vous l'avez les jeux vous et
robuste était une très bonne leçon je
veux dire je n'ai jamais faillir là ce
soir c'est bien
alors domergue et donnez votre pygmalion
et alors là vous avez connu un peu le
tout paris puisque anna de noailles par
exemple donné aux séances de pause est
rentré dans le milieu parisien grâce à
ça non oui enfin rentrer dans le milieu
parisien je voulais entrer dans le mid
et du théâtre parisien
alors de modèles et de meneuse de revue
comédienne disons d'une certaine façon
même si vous êtes très humble par
rapport à vos talents de comédienne nous
ait fait beaucoup de films beaucoup de
pièces oui j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
angleterre j'ai tout fait surtout
beaucoup de comédies musicales et puis
j'ai fait l'olympia j'ai fait la bcge
effet les capucines ouais et voilà bon
j'avais comment ici vous avez commencé
sur les planches à 17 ans avec francis
lopez et après vous avez sache c'est
vous qui doublent et martine carol dans
caroline chérie et oui c'était devenu le
pied de grue en u oui elle voulait pas
lancer une carafe on veut bien mais si
on peut pas
et qui vous double maintenant pour le
solde
vous avez présenté les premiers bikini
en tournée mondiale aux étés speakerine
à l'olympia oui et à cette époque que
vous rencontrez brassens et alors il
était fou d'amour de vous et vous vous
intéressez pas du tout faut pas exagérer
fou d'amour nous sommes enfin il était
charmant mais comme je voulais dit tout
à l'heure il faut savoir dire non
quelques fois oui alors il a écrit ça
pour vous brassens jolies fleurs dans
une
[Musique]
c'est là qu'il pourra pas
j'avais pagis est toujours en attendant
cette chanson parce que chaque fois que
vous inviter à dîner vous lui disiez non
demain quoi
c'était la tactique pour le faire fait
revenir bien sûr qu'il est basse et
d'argent c'est pas qu'il avait pas assez
d'argent c'est que c'était pas mon genre
donne d'une part et puis et puis j'avais
d'autres ambitions c'est quoi ça c'était
pas brassens est alors au cinéma vous
faites des rôles secondaires dans des
séries b vous étiez un peu numéro deux
derrière bardot à l'époque non oui j'ai
travaillé avec bar de huy et les
critiques disait que vous aviez des gens
de spirituel et vous étiez une ingénue
permet ainsi reste un terme plus
tellement un génie pervers s'est
terminée aujourd'hui d'abord je suis
passé je ne sais même pas s'il y en a
encore vous avez hollywood et vous
refusez hollywood vous refuser un
contrat de sept ans hollywood pourquoi
parce que d'abord je veux dire je ne
suis pas quelqu'un que l'on peut mettre
dans une cage donc là c'était vraiment
une très belle cage dorée mais qui ne me
convenait pas et puis resté sept ans
dans un endroit où vraiment je n'avais
aucun contrôle non je préférais robinet
il fallait vous faire peroxydée les
cheveux avoir un fiancé officiel effet
blonde comme marilyn monroe c'était pas
mon 6ème et tout le monde devait être
comme elle et voilà on vous dit j'ai
compris que je ne serai jamais une
grande star j'avais pas le physique et
si je voulais franchir une nouvelle
étape ça ne pouvait être que par le
mariage c'était le but si vous voulez
que je m'était imposé c'est de trouver
un mari ouais
pas forcément puissante non seulement
riche hip hop est immensément riche et à
la ferme étaient des limites toujours
non j'aurais pu épouser un je peux pas
vous dire moi un prix nobel
quelqu'un qui a fait vraiment le pouvoir
j'aime le pouvoir alors la richesse et
la puissance effectivement vous fasciner
et vous dites avec pas mal d'humour
derby il ya toujours des femmes qui
tombe toujours sur le plombier moi
chaque fois que j'ai vérifié venu vers
moi c'est la vérité mais je vous dis on
ne sait pas pourquoi les hommes riches
attire certaines femmes pourquoi est ce
que les hommes sont attirés par des
femmes comme moi j'ai bon aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que si on fait la course et
rockefeller où elle a pas d'autre
d'abord parce qu'on a la même ville même
way of life on connaît les mêmes gens
c'est plus facile votre surnom c'était
quand même la ruée vers l'or non je
dirais plutôt que c'était la ruée vers
le diamant vous voudrez d'un tout petit
tremplin et là vous tombez sur des
demandes rothschild dans un dîner en
1960 vous dites la beauté d'un homme ça
m'a jamais vraiment compté pour moi non
non et je trouve que ça n'a aucune
importance à guingamp ce jour peut-être
ouais ouais avant de passer à table soit
vous rencontrez dandiner il vous dit
vous portez un beau diamant dommage
qu'ils soient faux et c'était vrai jeu
c'est vrai et c'était vrai après vous
retrouvée assise à côté de lui il avait
une boîte une boîte à pilules où il y
avait une alliance cacher et voulu vivre
votre alliance est sûrement vrai mais
c'est pas sûr qu'elle soit sa place
c'est normal quand on est marié je sais
pas où est la vôtre si elles étaient
rois par don en principe c'est là où
elle doit être
exemplaire mais attendez ça veut dire
qu'il enlevait son alliance pour aller
sans sa femme dans les dîners à
exactement vous avez tout compris
n'est jamais seul non alors il ya un
problème c'est qu'elles demanderont s'il
venait de se marier alors c'est
difficile de faire divorcer un homme un
homme marié depuis trois ans n'ont
écouté c'est pas moi qui lui ai demandé
le divorce je pense que le couple ne
devait pas très bien marché et puis et
puis voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle le
coup de foudre nous le premier soir le
premier soir quand vous vous êtes vu ça
a été l'arrêt de versailles
je te dire que j'ai été très séduite oui
le coup de foudre non non simplement
c'est pour les emails qui m'ont bien
est-ce que vous avez coucher le premier
soir c'est vers elle c'est une question
qu'on va avoir beaucoup sur mon nom mais
je sais que je répondrai tout de suite
non mais je sais que c'est important je
crois qu'il faut faire l'averse
voyez-vous monsieur bachy il faut
toujours sert atteindre un homme quand
même temps vous l'avez fait attendre
leurs vêtements de non non non non non
non non non non je crois qu'il a dû
attendre moins de moi oui deux mois je
partais aussi en tournée alors c'est
pour ça hein et vous vous êtes resté
pendant trois ans dans l'ombre d'une
certaine façon vous l'avez laissé marier
avec cette femme et vous vous attendiez
enfin vous étiez pas mal et vous avez
acheté un appartement à la muette quand
même ce qu'il te le dire qu'en paca le
rapport à
4 pièces et la bulle est sympa oui mais
en fait j'avais autre chose avant faut
pas exagérer quand même oui exactement
toujours les rues thématique de jeu
alors il finit par divorcer 1 j'ai bien
pris là
et alors problème c'est qu'il vous dit
je peux pas je peux pas été posée parce
que tu n'es pas juive oui mais vous qu'à
cela ne tienne
miracle vous êtes enceinte
oui j'attends mon fils
non mais ça tombait bien disons vraiment
ça tombait bien non écoutez un enfant ça
ce programme cet homme n'avait pas
d'enfant il voulait un enfant nous avons
fait un enfant voulait bien peu de monde
j'ai accompli non non pas du tout là
haut la ola pas du tout cher monsieur
alors ça vous vous trompez complet me
dire moi je vous pose non mais vous me
posez la question je vous réponds non
cet homme voulait un enfant il s'est dit
voilà une fille saine je vais faire un
enfant avec un bon donc il était au
courant ah oui vaut mieux marié en
catastrophe en robe de chambre à
l'hôpital parce que vous étiez quand
même heure mariée chez moi pas l'hôpital
attention j'ai signé chez moi en robe de
chambre c'est vrai puisque j'étais
couché j'attendais mon fils et là vous
vous convertissez au judaïsme
vous êtes accepté par la famille ça a
été difficile pour vous de d'apprendre
le talmud et tout ça pas du tout
absolument pas partir du moment où vous
êtes vous êtes capable de tout
enregistrer et d'être une bonne élève je
l'étais j'ai été convertie par le grand
rabbin qu'un plan kaplan qui a été un
homme est absolument extraordinaire et
j'ai passé je dois dire 2 à me convertir
et maintenant donc vous êtes de religion
juive c'est non moi j'ai un canapé
convertible du slam est coupée
alors vous dit en parlant de ça
d'ailleurs en parlant du fait que les
rothschild a accepté une fille qui
venait quand même d'un milieu très
modeste vous dites je me demande si les
marchés les époux marché aurait voulu
d'un rothschild comme gendre
je ne le crois pas bon c'est vrai oui
c'est vrai qu'on sait qu'il aurait
sûrement pas ouais bien que bien que je
vais vous dire qu'entre schild a paraît
il ya plus de yap religion il ya plus de
frontières je pense que c'est normal que
si monsieur marché avait avait eu une
fille jeu en définitive je crois qu'il
aurait accepté alors il avait pas mon
caractère à monsieur le baron quand même
a dit oh la la soupe au lait
c'est vrai vous disent ils en auraient
fait fuir plus d'une wii et et macho le
baron et j'aime les hommes machos c'est
un homme comme les hommes doivent l'être
a laissé le terminal est ce que la liste
et pas des mines a maintenant des matchs
ya des matches où tu es gaulliste et
mais comme tous les hommes armés exigent
oui les coureurs ça écoutez moi je
connais pas d'hommes qui ne soit pas
coureurs c'est vrai vous dites la
fidélité masculine n'existe pas à mes
yeux ça n'existe pas - il en faisait
cette phrase merveilleuse que je
voudrais que toutes les femmes de france
écoute aimer un homme c'est accepter de
le voir heureux avec une autre que vous
[Applaudissements]
ça me change de isabelle alonso c'est
sur la générosité il aimait profondément
quelqu'un beaucoup de femmes vous disant
j'adore mon mari j'adore mon mari bon
bah si tu n'aime tellement laissez-le
vivre sa vie puis vous vous aviez été sa
maîtresse pendant trois ans avant qu'ils
vous épouser donc malgré tout vous
saviez qu'il avait des maîtresses
puisque vous aviez vous la robe de votre
côté vous pratiquez aussi le
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais lu de vous quelque part
n'est entendu non
donc il faut avant tout être discrète
mais
alors c'est vrai quand quand vous parlez
de vous vous comparez souvent une geisha
voire à une esclave ou dit la femme est
fait pour plaire et écouter ça me paraît
normal quand on aimera entre de 2,2 du
bureau qu'il a envie de vous parler la
moindre des choses est de l'écouter tout
pour éviter le divorce c'est à dire que
vous n'êtes pas tout accepter plutôt
qu'un divorce oui parce que vous dites
il vaut mieux être trompé que divorcé ça
demande moins de formalités exactement
c'est très cynique mais quand on voit
les désastres si vous voulez de ses
enfants d'occasions ouais moi ça me rend
malade tous ces jeunes qui se marient et
quatre ans après divorce c'est pas les
enfants qui sont l'occasion les pauvres
en informations les enfants d'occasions
pour le prochain si vous prenez la dame
vous prenez les gosses avec bon et si
vous prenez les gosses avec 7 c'est
vraiment on voulait on vous les
présentez vous êtes obligés d accepter
sont des enfants d'occasions je suis
désolé je prenne forme non non moi non
plus je n'aime pas mais c'est la vie qui
est comme ça bon et si les gens
faisaient un tout petit peu plus
attention avant de se marier il n'y
aurait pas tous les drames qu'il ya
aujourd'hui et voilà donc au bar dont
les gens sont crus au salon c'est ça le
fond du problème
donc pas divorcer et un grand conseil
aussi dans la grande série des grand
conseil de la baronne de rothschild
jamais avoué c'est la principale des
choses celle ci vous avouez vous êtes
vous êtes morts d'abord il ne faut
jamais demander à votre mari est ce que
tu m'as trompé parce que bien entendu
vous êtes c'est dramatique d'entendre
oui mais 31 et mathis je vous dit il va
chercher un peu à se faire pardonner
comme auprès de sa mère mais en fait une
femme lui pardonnera jamais bien des
façons voilà jamais alors messieurs s'il
vous plaît ne vous ai jamais n'avoue
jamais dit marc d'al hilal à agen
alors vous vouliez créer un moment je
pense que c'est devenu cette histoire
une assurance divorce oui j'en ai parlé
ce matin justement avancer ça tient
toujours pas ce que c'est il ya
longtemps de ça c'était vraiment dans
les années soit début des 70's vaincre
et bien sûr quand je veux quelque chose
j'ai mais vous savez alors crois qu'en
mais l'acceptation ceux du bord c'est à
dire que je voudrais à partir du moment
où les hommes divorce et les femmes
divorce ils doivent normalement payer
une pension alimentaire si l'homme et de
bonne foi il paiera si malheureusement
il ne l'est pas la femme se retrouve
sans rien s'il perd sa situation même
s'il veut payer alors je crois qu'on
pourrait créer si vous voulez une
assistance ou les assurances se
substituerait à l'état ou aux marines
voilà mais alors pourquoi vous avez
arrêté d'en parler pendant 30 ans je me
suis énervé demande non pas du tout non
c'est que chaque fois que j'ai présenté
le projet on a dit c'est pas réalisable
c'est un encouragement au divorce puis
quand on voit qu'il y en a tellement je
me dis j'ai rien l'encourager du tout
par exemple vous êtes pour le solaire
maternelle oui j'ai dû remplacer que les
femmes devraient toucher un salaire pour
s'occuper des enfants le rqra pour pas
pour toutes les femmes pas pour toutes
les femmes vous avez des femmes sont
tous obligés de travailler qui gagne
très peu d'argent est alors à ce moment
là je dis pourquoi ne donne-t-on pas un
salaire au lieu de créer des crèches de
construire sans arrêt sans arrêt de
nouveaux établissements pour mettre des
enfants qui ont besoin de leur mère et
des femmes qui ne sont pas fait pour
travailler bon au moins qu'on leur donne
un salaire et tout le monde y gagne
celles qui peuvent et qui en
intelligence ou le les études ou houle
envie surtout celles qui ont envie
pourquoi pas moi je fais absolument ravi
tout à fait pour vous pensez quoi des
chiennes de garde
écoutez moi j'admire beaucoup madame
alonso parce qu'elle est elle un
parcours fantastique
elle est une très grande chef
d'entreprise j'estime que cette femme a
beaucoup de mérite de défendre pardon
pensez quoi des chaînes de govou qui
avait monté les lévriers afghans de
garde rappelons l'histoire
non je crois qu'il en faut je ne serais
capable de faire le travail qu'elle fait
ça à la table bon j'agite d'une autre
façon mais je pense qu'elle est très
très très utile au contraire ouais vous
la soutenez je ne dis pas que je la
soutiens surtout les générations je la
soutiens aux je vais vous dire dans le
domaine de la génétique a
touché bonne santé l'attend maintenant
vous étiez chez vous aussi s'il vous
plaît
nadine de rothschild finalement votre
façon d'envisager la vie conjugale ainsi
que vous venez nous le raconter est-ce
que c'est pas finalement de la
prostitution bourgeoise
j'ai épousé un homme riche c'est vrai
mon mari mon mari n'était pas l'aider
sûrement pas un homme fidèle et gelé
quand même gardé pendant 40 ans et je
voulais dit quand vous aimez quelqu'un
vous fait des sacrifices peu importe les
sacrifices vous avez affirmé je suis
contre le divorce et mon mari était un
homme extraordinaire j'étais sûr femme
et je le suis un steak et voilà si
c'était à refaire je recommence de son
régime
alors entendu
l'amour est une affaire de femmes chez
robert laffont par aline de rothschild
donc bajoues demandé de recommencer
ronaldinho il faut apprendre il faut le
faire enfin que les pieds tu es fort
avec les mains ténue l'asie
alors j baffie montrez-lui sa 1 2 3
alors donc dans l'avant propos du livre
vous évoquez la disparition du baron
d'une façon assez tendre d'ailleurs
effectivement et puis vous parler des
femmes célèbres que vous avez connu ou
approché comme actrice ou comme baronne
de rothschild
alors on va essayer de les passer en
revue un petit peu vous dire quelles
sont leurs spécificités la première
catégorie c les marathoniennes alors
dans cette catégorie ya par exemple
jackie kennedy camilla parker bowles
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de particulier les
marathoniennes ce sont des femmes qui
aiment le pouvoir ce sont des femmes qui
ont envie d'être célèbre donc elles
savent qu'elles ne peuvent être célèbre
qu'à travers un homme donc elles
choisissent effectivement l'homme qui va
les mettre sur un piédestal et qui sera
d'elle last house on considérait comme
une marathonienne vous je pense oui oui
alors aprilia n'est pas de chance aurait
évidemment il ya lister leurs il ya
marilyn monroe christina onassis romy
schneider j'ai dis pas que ce soit
le mirail alors je suis pas que ce sens
pas les pas de chance je dis que ce sont
des midinettes qui veulent absolument
que l'amour soit au rendez vous bon
l'amour peut l'être cinq minutes mais
pas toute une vie donc c'est pour ça qu
elisabeth a tellement divorcer que remy
malheureusement est morte d'amour elle
est morte d'amour parce que c'est très
charmant de dire il faut qu'on aime
quand même à tout prix mais c'est pas
tout la vis vous pensez qu'à un moment
mais c'est plus d'amour faut continuer
quand maintenant je crois que la passion
la passion ces cinq ans je parle d'un
patient physique bon après vous faites
un accord vous fait vous avez une vie
avec des enfants vous avez une vie très
remplie mais ça n'est plus du tout la
même chose vous n'êtes plus la maîtresse
vous êtes la femme l'épousé la mère des
enfants l'accompagnent c'est différent
ne pensez pas qu'on puisse être à la
fois la maman et la [ __ ] vous a
sûrement pas ouais sûrement pas et
heureusement d'ailleurs alors après y
avait ma ma alors celles qui font des
bons petits plats pour garder leur mari
alors il ya sophia loren maria callas
était comme sagna gallas oui c'était une
femme oui comment je les ai vus vivre
avec avec onassis et s était vraiment la
mama
les coéquipières là c'est simone
signoret avec mon temps hillary clinton
avec bill clinton son légendaire
par danton et charlton et chardy
alors c'est quoi ça
c'est ce que normalement une femme doit
être un moment de sa vie oui et ça me
paraît tout à fait normal moi j'étais
une partenaire idéale avec mon mari
c'est à dire que on travaillait ensemble
dans beaucoup de choses et c'est pour ça
que je dis même si nous avions divorcé
il m'aurait posé parce qu'on était on
était une espèce de 10 l'extraordinaire
les indépendants claudia diana mouna
ayoub c'est quoi les caractéristiques et
indépendante
ce sont des femmes qui veulent vivre
avec l'argent de leurs maris seul ouais
voilà et ça c'est très difficile parce
qu'une fois que vous avez cette
célébrité je pense qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'hommes qui s'intéressent à
vous ah oui parce que vous avez de
l'argent c'est très difficile pour une
femme d'être riche seul il faut toujours
un homme derrière une femme vous savez
vous terminez bas rhin avec les
admirables mais qui à l'abbé gamme que
lui personne connaît le jeu social et
réveillère
la gamme grace kelly oui farah diba oui
en quoi elles sont admirables non elles
ont elles ont tenu leurs engagements ils
ont signé un contrat ils sont allés au
bout de leurs oeufs de ce qu'elle avait
signé moi je trouve ça normal et bien
alors vous comprendrez comment les
aimants un abîme de rothschild qu'on
vous fasse une interview alerte aux
roses
en à bouche pendant l'été
en accouche pas on en ignore le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour en combat tous
les lieux sont possibles d'abord un peu
d'imagination
oui plutôt que le métro
donné le mot incroyable
raisonnable ou chercher la sécurité ou
la performance
la sécurité
est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour j'ai besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour oui préfère un homme qui
fait bien l'amour mais qu'un fidèle ou
un homme qui fait mal l'amour mais qui
est fidèle un homme qui fait bien
l'amour et qui est un fidèle
vous préféreriez qu'un homme vous quitte
pour une femme ou pour un homme
je pense que là je serais très surpris
et effectivement si c'était pour un
homme mais et puis pas non ça vous
gênerait plus que ce soit pour ça mais
je n'aime pas dans le flou non mais si
vous aviez un homme qui vous trompe avec
un homme vous auriez autant de
compréhension que c'était une femme si
je ne peut pas diriger je laisse faire
ouais voilà vous préférez un homme qui
couche avec une autre en pensant à vous
un homme qui couche avec vous en pensant
une autre c'est ce qu'on appelle quand
même si vous voulez quand un homme vous
dis je ne vous avais jamais trompé ma
femme alors j'ai dit moi je vois pas la
différence entre un monsieur qui va de
5h à 7h avec une dame et revient à la
maison avec un grand sourire de bonne
humeur quand monsieur qui le soir parce
le même temps avec sa femme et qui pense
à la voisine n'y a pas de différence oui
alors vous préférez finalement dû
coucher avec une autre en pensant avons
exactement
elle s'ouvrait dans le couple bush même
pas la question dans le couple il faut
tous diront rien savoir vous pensez
qu'il faut rien savoir à 9 ans y à
savoir est-ce que vous pensez que
embrasser s'est trompé
non non on peut embrasser une femme ou
un homme sans tromper est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper
je ne vais pas vous répondre voilà
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu